yeah brand new engine i'll just run it
in so
it was a bit fun on the way here well
you just put like a really powerful
engineer a really old car
yeah pretty much hey you need to check
this guy just connect this guy was
homeless is that correct
it was in a shed in a shed and he came
to the property investors crash course
2015
2015 since then he's done so many
property deals
hey what is up my name is samuel leeds i
have been in property now for 12 years
i've done over 300 property deals but
rather than you just hearing from me
every week me talking about what i've
done i like to get
other perspectives from other property
investors and also my students so i'm
going to introduce you right now to a
guy called josh connect
now this is his second time on my
youtube channel
uh he was on about 18 months ago or so
he is
full time in property he's in a lot of
different types of deals
he came to my property investors crash
course in 2015
five years ago and now we're still
friends he's still doing deals and he's
sat here in
my house josh welcome to winners on a
wednesday thank you so much pleasure to
be here again so you've done
you've done so many different types of
property deals and talking to you is
like a wealth of
there's a wealth of knowledge and thank
you so much you've seen good
bad ugly absolutely we've done deals
sort of together i've sold you this yeah
yeah we sell deals you yeah you referred
them so yeah we've effectively done jv's
yeah you've had problems which i've come
and helped you
yet with saved me a couple of times yeah
like let's be frank
but but also you know you've become
friends we've had dinners together and
things so
josh um thanks for coming down why don't
you just tell us
for anyone that hasn't seen the first
interview that we did
what's your kind of back story back
story so
i at eight years old i used to pull out
the draw
under the phone which in those days was
connected to the wall and look at all
the rolls of cash
now those were there that my parents had
a an annex on the back of the house
and every month they would put the roll
of cash which was rent into the draw and
eventually go into the bank
yeah but that was enough for me to know
that property works
if you do it right is that is that they
were paying their landlord or is that
you know so
um the the tenant in in basically an
annex of
our house was paying my parents right so
that was one of their
and you just like the look of that good
cat i was like hell yeah i could buy a
lot of sweets with that and yeah
i could buy a lot of you know cars and
whatever okay um
from that and it was like if i get into
property it will be it will be
i'll have a draw full of cash basically
yeah um
so then what like most people i did
nothing
until 2008 crashed when that happened
and i went ah
it's the crash i need this to buy cheap
houses
um and so then i started getting
involved in property doing stuff
i managed uh to get someone to take the
mortgage
because i wasn't mortgageable and
someone to front the fans and i bought
my first house in the middle of devon
which i've just actually sold um which
saved me in lockdown
i might add we'll come on to that later
um
but it was rent the rooms out uh it was
my own house effectively um and that
from day one paid for all my living
expenses all my fuel
all the mortgage and i was kind of like
wow
this is good yeah um and you bought that
in what 2008
it was a little bit after 2008. uh good
you waited for the crack
the repercussion of this yeah so i
waited a bit i also wanted to make sure
i knew what i was doing
what year was that when you bought that
i probably waited a couple of years
probably 11 maybe 2011 maybe 12.
around about that time 2011
especially in devon was where property
prices started shooting up again
so did you buy before that boom or was
it drawing that burn well i don't really
know
i didn't have my eye on the market that
much i just knew my strategy was
buy a house that was rubbish do it up
take a mortgage out on it that's
effectively pulling all your money out
if you can yeah and rent it out yeah
that was
that was as much as the plan i had at
the time right so i knew that worked
because i've seen houses
that sold for this but it's been
refurbed and put back on the market yeah
so
and auctions were a great place because
i could go and see who bought the
property
go and speak to them and go can i come
and look around your house yeah and you
know if you ask enough people someone's
going to say yes
and so i've got to watch people sort of
do it before i'd even done anything
then i bought it then and actually you
know i've had it
for years as a single let and it's been
okay
but the strategy when i was buying it
was it needs to be
in need of refurb it needs to have a
garage and it needs to have a toilet
like a really newspaper on and it
matched all three of those
three of those so i bought it yeah that
was it so that was like the first
the first property to your and at the
time you didn't know you were going to
end up being
like a professional property investor or
did you know i knew i wanted to be in
property
i left school we went into the building
trade and then decided that that wasn't
really where i wanted to go which i
didn't cover a little bit on the
previous video
um and then once i'd been to
pin meetings and property networking
events
i kind of got oh this is exciting i
could really do something with this
it was real world yeah i could see the
refurb i could see the refinance
and it was like okay this makes sense to
me did you first hear me speak was like
was it a pin meeting did i sell you a
deal
you did and did i sell it well you did
talk to me about sales
um the sales
as such um was a gentle pitch
my pitch to you yeah it was yeah but i
mean i mean the reason i say talk to me
about sales is someone who's gone
through property bought many properties
sold properties
i think you might disagree with me i
think that sales
is a very important aspect to property
business because i think that
money comes from people not property it
comes from tenants it comes from valuers
it comes from investors it comes from
joint venture partners absolutely even
when
the value goes up and then you sell it
the value hasn't gone up really what's
happened is someone said the value has
gone up
so you need to be able to be good with
people so that's why i think it's just
so important to be able to close to be
able to
find out what people want give it to
them okay so um
are we talking the sales process are we
talking about the actual
selling of the deal to an investor how
do you mean sales
when i say i'm talking about i sell to
it i sell to my tenants
if a potential tenant comes in or sells
them if a tenant has a problem
and they're kicking off and going crazy
you have to sell them on the idea that
it's okay and come up with it all the
time you do
um i think everything is sales it is
i had to sell you to come on this
channel yeah you did it
it worked you're obviously all right
yeah i sold my how much did you pay me
for that first deal that i sold you
remember
about three grand about three grand and
i've done hundreds of that
sort of stuff yeah um so i've still got
it i still haven't refinanced it
um right but you will there i will do
marketing as well it's probably got
40 five fifty grand worth of equity in
it good i know the thing is marketing i
think people forget
that property investing is a business
yes
it's like you you have you have a
product and then you have a customer
then you have a marketplace your product
is your house your tenant is your
customer yes your marketplace is what do
people want
what are people looking for your
investors are also your customers yes
and if you have repeat customers you
know you've got a decent business
and you don't have to have millions and
millions of investors to have a really
substantial business
correct because if you're doing property
that's uh let me give you uh
a little bit more detail about the
property that i bought on the way up to
do the last video
yeah yeah you i think you bought a house
that same day i did yeah i went up there
i i phoned my investor on the way and
said look i've seen this property i'm
going to go and have a
look at it are you interested i need 150
grand to buy it
there's 145 plus stamp legals they're
about 150.
he said yeah right no problem let me
know um so i viewed it went yeah it's
amazing
are you in yeah yeah i mean and then i
drove up and spoke to you
um so it was 145 purchase price by the
time i'd done about six grand refurb
stamp legals few
little bits uh staging as well i was all
in for
one six two and a half one six two and a
half and that's
literally that was everything yeah did
you buy catch i bought cash yeah okay
but you use the investors oh yeah
use my own yeah um why would you
um i've got investors that shared a
profit with me they're very happy with
that does that have to do anything i
don't have to
refinance my portfolio to buy the next
deal or just use their money and pay
them back
so um during lockdown i got that
revalued at 200 grand
nice six grand refurb um yes
legal so um i took out 75 loan to value
i don't like to
rack up my loan to values too much um i
think it did get down valued a little
bit
because when before lockdown i had two
estate agents come around
i normally have three but i had two both
of them said 220.
the valuer came in and said 200. yeah i
took 75
to value so 150 out yeah so you left in
about 12 grand
yeah and then i rented it out during the
um
lockdown and the refinance period i was
renting out two nurses
um so it works out now with the rental
profit from that period i've left about
five grand in it wow nice so it will be
less than a one year payback period and
how much how what's the monthly cash
flow on that now uh getting 8.90 rent
nice okay i think it's 260 or something
so josh
talk to me okay because i know you've
done a lot of joint ventures
i love doing ventures you love about
people ha and this is why i want to talk
about sales i want to talk about
marketing
but but the real what people want to
know
is how to buy a house without using any
of their money what people want to know
is how to become financially free or
people want to
yeah but but i'll say yes that's what
you want
but to get there you need to understand
sales marketing because yeah
joint venture you had to sell that guy
and believe it or not i don't think a
house will sell itself
if you have a brilliant house i used to
be an estate agent and i had to sell
houses
unless you market the house you don't
market it no one's gonna know exists
exactly and then if you can't sell it
you've got to sell people on the idea of
going around and looking around it then
you have to go around with them and you
have to
not like an annoying sales person but
you have to find out what do you want
okay
show them the right house and then you
have to close and say you know how would
you like to pay
yes you know what's your time frame when
are you ready to you know should we get
started
um so which which actually brings me on
to a point
like estate agents don't ask the right
questions no they don't
to the people that are selling it's like
you know they just go in and they assume
that everyone wants the best price for
their house
yeah which if if you're in a difficult
situation it's not necessarily the most
important thing correct
it's speed yeah because sometimes people
want speed
yeah i gotta say this this month i'll
drop it 25
i need to sell it this month other times
people say well i'm not really in a rush
if you can get the maximum premium price
for it i'll consider selling
then that's cool then put it on the
market and sell it for that but the
people that
might be in uh a difficult situation
where
um you know they're moving abroad and
they've got to get rid of it or
something
similar i mean there's hundreds of
reasons why
they sometimes forget to tell the estate
agent that that's
important and and the estate agent will
put it on for you know a decent price it
will take a while to sell but any yeah
there's a buy for everything
however if they forget to tell the
estate agent and the agent doesn't ask
because they never do yeah yeah which is
more important the price or the
speed for instance yeah then that can
sometimes get forgotten and then people
are really in this sticky situation if
they're getting
you know repossessed or something and
they haven't sold in time how do you get
these joint venture partners
sales okay um i had hundreds of coffees
yeah i went to networking meetings um
and i collected many business cards as i
could
i i asked what's your objective
so what's your time scale and what's
your pot all right and these are three
things that i
actually learned from susana cole if you
don't mind we met there no no
and you did i know you've done lots of
other training you've done yeah
i'm a massive fan of training yeah it's
got its place and it is really really
vital
for you not to ruin your
pot effectively because right at the
beginning when you you and your money
are easily parted if you give it to
someone that's
unscrupulous and you lose it all you're
starting from zero if you're starting
with a part which is better than where i
started
you've got a good chance as long as you
do the training and you do a property
that
so actually investing in yourself you're
almost protecting your money
yeah absolutely i agree with that so you
know joint ventures so you just
start off you do a lot of networking i
phone people
i just hit the phones i have days well
off phone 120 people
and i'll just go hey it's josh um
what are you up to in property um to be
fair i have the same spiel
it's hi it's josh 2b property i met you
at whatever event
i'm just phoning to find out a little
bit more about what you're doing
property yeah that's my standard
intro to any first course i met them at
property networking
and then i just shut up i was like take
notes okay what you do
and then okay great you're interested in
this area can i put you in touch with
whoever if
i'm not working in that area or it's
great i've got a project in the area do
you want to come and have a look
and by building that
that sounds horrible sales funnel um
you get people that you know like trust
and will buy from you and you will buy
with that it's called
building your list yeah that's what it
is
i'd rather you wipe my money than wipe
my list
sure the person who has the biggest list
is the person who's gonna win
provided you've kept up with the people
on your list
yeah follow-up right and that's where
it's all about
and you've got to actually sell to that
list yeah and people think
that sounds dirty and horrible selling
is serving
people will only buy something the
person that joint ventured with you is
going to be like thank you so much
oh totally every time can can we do it
again selling is serving if someone
gives you money they're giving you a
certificate of thanks
yeah totally totally the thing is if
they've had an amazing experience
they've bought a house they've seen it
they followed you through
they'll go can we do that again yeah and
i go
yeah what have you spent the money on a
holiday a ridiculous car
great let's do it again yeah um yeah so
that's that's just a little fun bit so
okay so you've got a list yeah you
network you go online i go to coffees
you're very much like um i mean you are
online but yeah face to face
very much face to face yeah i'm trying
to get you a bit more online
yeah yeah i'm working on that i'm i'm
not very good at marketing myself out to
be honest
um i have got a a youtube channel um to
be property
yeah i have got my website check your
youtube channel out
2b property check it out yes there are
some terrible videos
from when i first started but was it as
corny as the videos
that i had you on when i was selling
your houses probably not no no when i
started my youtube channel it was the
corniest thing it was great but
if you if you're not embarrassed about
your if you if you know if you're not
embarrassed about yourself from one year
ago
if you don't if you don't then you
haven't grown you've not grown if you
don't look at yourself from a year or
two ago and go oh man i'm embarrassed
you've not grown and if you can't even
look at yourself from a year or two ago
because there's no footage or there's
nothing to see
then you didn't put yourself out there
enough definitely that's my that's my
philosophy
and to be honest um i now class myself
uh i've always you know since then been
an investor
but i'm officially a successful investor
because i've got my first hater
yeah yeah got firsthand i love it well
you know what i always say
for every 100 people you've helped
you're going to have at least one hater
and if you haven't got any haters
they're not trying hard enough
you've not you've not impacted enough
people yeah you've not impacted enough
people because
if if no one knows who you are then you
do something wrong and that
here's the thing that's marketing
marketing is in
very simple languages awareness so
people know you exist
now they might not like you they might
not know if they can trust you they
might know but
that's marketing and then as you nurture
your list and follow up and get to know
them yeah that's part of the
investigation that's part of the
nurturing that's part of the serving
and then you're selling but you're only
selling to people that want your product
need your product
and they don't have to be pushed into it
you can go
hey it's josh how are you going
oh you've got some money to invest okay
i've got a project
are you interested shall we out for a
coffee have a chat about it yeah that's
as hard as the pitch needs to be
yeah if they know you like you trust you
yeah and i think as well
asking closing and that's actually
asking people for the business
once you know that they want it so so
i'll do pre-qualify questions i'll be
like
you know listen uh have you got the
funds in place yes if i can find
something that that ticks
you know your boxes are your business
where you can move today yes what are
you looking for then listen listen
listen listen listen listen listen
all right i've actually got something
that ticks the boxes for you
here's it boom then i'll sell it i'll go
over the numbers they'll like it
and then i'll ask them great so are you
in a position where you can move on this
uh yeah probably great when would you
like to get started it's just
for me it's just asking questions but
asking the right questions yeah
people are scared of that yeah people
don't want rejection people don't want
to be told
no we were told as growing up we were
told you know
don't be cheeky don't do don't talk to
strangers yeah don't get told no
no is a bad thing but actually if you
don't want to get told no and you don't
want to talk to strangers how on earth
are you gonna are you gonna make it in
business if you don't talk to strangers
what that's the opposite you've got to
talk to strangers
exactly yeah even me i'm strange i'll
talk to myself you're very strange dude
that's why i like you yeah exactly um
all right talk to me through some other
deals then so you've that that one was
when we last met you yes i bought that
one um one
yeah 145 162 and a half all in
150 out and yeah about four
four grand left in four five something
like that uh so what i've
got three offers out accepted at the
moment
great uh one was off market which
uh came as a result of buying one that
was on market because he had another one
in the background they hadn't put the
market yet i said hey do you want to bet
sell both
i'll buy both yeah okay great thank you
very much
so numbers on those they are and i think
in the last video i said to you
i don't source out deals very much
because i phone people up and go
do you want to join venture and they go
yes okay fine we're joined venturing
and so with this first flat i said right
i'm going to sell one out
just so i've been through the process
i'm all registered and legal as a source
of insurance and i see and all that kind
of stuff
but i've never sold anything out because
i joined venture so right
market it put it out send it to my email
list
no one phone no phone right that's how
i'm buying it
yeah i bought it okay i can't wait any
longer i put it out
three four five days no one had said
anything about it interesting it's
amazing
142 worth 200 to 220
with a six grand refund it's kind of the
deal i found on the way out
yeah this is another one of those and
i'm like forget this i'm done
okay all right that's so funny because i
know so many investors myself included
that have done that exact thing they're
like
they put a deal out it doesn't sell
you'd think if it didn't sell you might
be thinking maybe this went wrong a bit
but you're so sold on the deals being is
good yourself you're like
this is such a good deal and it ticks
you off so badly that no one buys it you
think
forget it i'm going to buy it myself
exactly so
that was the first one what okay why
couldn't you sell the deal that's
interesting is that because your list
isn't big enough
is that because your email wasn't worded
well uh i don't need to help you on that
you do need to help me on that because
um
yeah because somebody wasn't right i
don't know when you structure a joint
venture
how do you structure it so this was a
source deal yeah but but the
when you do a jv in general okay so they
they basically uh
buy the property in their name right
because if
not not all the time um some of my
trusted investors would just send me
money but
generally if i'm working with someone
they want the property in their name
because otherwise they're gonna freak
out they bought a house it's not in
their name
and they'll just wobble in their name so
solely in their name
they buy it um they pay for the refurb
and all the refinance
and at the end get three valuations
take an average the average would be the
assumed sale price if they're buying me
out or we sell it
okay and the difference between our
costs and the sale price which is the
profit is split 50 50.
okay and you have a contract in place
right yep contracts in place
um if i'm buying the property um
in my name and the investors paid for it
they'll have a first charge yeah
um so it's got to be legally tight
because the thing is with joint ventures
is it is a blank piece of paper
it is you can every deal is different
depending on how much money they're
putting in how much money you're putting
in or you might not putting in any money
you've got to have key roles
responsibilities and clear contracts
yeah solicitors draw up everything yeah
yeah that's just cost of the deal yeah a
couple of grand the solicitors will
okay the contract so these are flips
that you're doing and you're buying a
house doing it up selling it by refurb
sell
occasionally um i will want to keep the
house if i've brought it in my name i
can do
if they want to keep the house they just
pay me out what would be
effectively half the profit yeah as if
we sold it what's the most challenging
uh property thing that you've had to go
through in your life oh
was a property
it was a six thousand square foot x
window house uh
x window uh factory
yeah a six thousand square foot in the
center of
bristol in saint paul's uh it wasn't my
deal
but i fund-raised to be able to
buy it because it was on a an option
it's like a lease option right yes yes
so i was talking to someone networking
event say
i've got this deal it's on a lease
option i need um
300 grand to buy it um and we're going
to go for planning
etc and we're going to then set at
auction
the plot opposite was the same size as
solid auction from a million quid with
planning
no-brainer the only issue was
i hadn't done my due diligence on who i
was working with
and we just were not compatible um
so a year down the line my investors are
due out a ton of money
i actually because of the unknowns i do
this on a fixed return
so they're due out ton of money the
planning hasn't gone in
um we haven't progressed any further on
the deal
and i'm going right i need my money out
mate
so it all got a bit tense and
complicated yeah
a lot of money locked in a couple of
investors
that were in there i managed to
refinance
other investors in to pay out some of
the investors one of my investors was
paid back late and as a result lost me
150 grand investor um but basically
150 grand yeah because the investor was
um
paid back late yeah because we had to go
to solicitors to basically try and get
my money out of the deal because it was
like
this was the timeline the planning
hasn't happened yeah
right just pay me out you can do the
deal just pay me out
you know this is the timeline and it's
up um
so yeah that all got a bit bit tense
really solicitors were involved
what would you say oh i learned masses
from i was going to say that i mean
what would you say the lessons were from
that because it sounds unpleasant
can happen in property and even if you
are the most experienced professional
cautious investor in the world you can
still have problems and you can
still have things disastrously go wrong
at times
um in this case what was the main lesson
that you got from that whole experience
don't work with someone you don't know
properly yeah yeah okay
so one of my rules is i have to have at
least touch
uh i have to have at least 10 touch
points
whether it's phone calls coffees meats
investor
events tours whatever i need to have met
them or had some decent contact
for 10 occasions on 10k so you you know
them well
i know well that's got to be at least
six months this is my advice to you as
well okay because flipping that the
other way
right so for someone to do business with
you
they're going to want to they're going
to want to spend time with you they're
going to want to know you like you trust
you
well by default of my rules i won't work
with anyone that i haven't met 10 times
now but here's the thing
here's the thing right they say that the
average person will only do business
with you serious business when they
spend seven hours with you
however hear this when you have books
that take seven hours to read when you
have a youtube video going out every day
most of my fans my audience my people
they feel like they know me inside out
they know my flaws
they know my strengths they know my
character they know my views they know
my friggin family right
they're your extended family yeah
they're my extended family
i've been doing youtube for five years
i've been
in property for 12. so for me when i
want to do a joint venture with someone
if i'm saying hey do you want to fund
this deal
people people know me
and if they don't want to do business
with me because they don't like me at
least they know me enough you know they
don't like me
they so so that's why i'm saying to you
as someone that's just doing business
with people and has grown your list
there's nothing more powerful than doing
youtube
writing books letting people know who
you are is branding people sometimes say
samuel why would you if you're making so
much money from property why would you
teach people
and the answer is is it it's not really
a very good question but i'll give it an
answer anyway
number one is because i really enjoy it
and not everything is about money yeah
so when you become
wealthy now it's okay what do i enjoy i
enjoy
this i enjoy having conversations with
people like you on youtube i enjoy
training people
but number two is in having a brand
i.e writing books teaching youtube all
this stuff
do running programs most of my joint
venture partners
are my students you know most of my
um most of wh you met hearing me hearing
me train hearing me speak now
it wasn't at my own event you came later
but so
the joint venture partners the investors
the the friendships the business i mean
geez i have people messaging me every
day have you got deals
have you got i have people i have
tenants messaging me i'd love to be one
of your tenants if you've got any
properties in birmingham really like so
i think that's the power of branding
what do you think about that
absolutely absolutely yeah and part of
my branding is the hat right you'll see
it on
the website in the logo and that kind of
thing um and that does help
people recognize who i am if they have
seen me on your video or whatever
they'll go hey josh i saw you on you
know this video
and that'll start a conversation and the
the the power of
of what you have created which i'm
working on ie
the youtube and and all that kind of
thing um
the benefits are huge yeah um
so from as a direct result of being on
windows on a wednesday
i then came to christmas dinner and at
that dinner i agreed to joint venture in
southampton with one of the other
attendees yeah so
directly that has caused me to do
another deal that caused me it's
probably the wrong word but
as a result i've got another deal that's
now making me money yeah that's great um
so you know it's it's hugely powerful um
and yeah i need some education on them
on marketing for sure
for sure however i have decided over
lockdown that i was going to write a
book
yeah good which is like a massive thing
for me because i'm so dyslexic you
wouldn't believe
um but it's it's yeah it's like someone
else trying to train for brain surgery
that's how difficult mia writing the
book is
um and it's gonna be a lot about
property but a lot about my story
because
you know in the past i've spoken to you
about you know i was living in a shed
you know at one time talk to me a little
bit about that because i i mean
honestly i know you've obviously told me
and stuff but it is an incredible
your your journey you were like homeless
at one point
yeah so it was kind of at the same time
as i was doing that deal that was all
going wrong
um with the window factory i'd put all
of my investors funds into
that deal which stupidly was someone
else's deal i didn't know very well
um you know but you live and learn
that was all going wrong it was a
factory so in bristol
um my parents had just passed away and
at the time we were in rented
accommodation so
we could no longer keep the house
because the parents were
um basically funding that for for their
care and that kind of thing
dad went into a home and i was like i'd
stopped everything
to look after them because they were
both really up and and
when the inevitable happened they both
passed away it's like
wow i don't actually have anywhere to go
all my investors money is locked up in
this deal which is going completely
wrong
um i better find someone to live yeah
and i had a really wrecked old mondeo
that i slept in for a while this is
terrible
um and and basically i got told there
was a shed
on the edge of the train tracks in
croydon um well great i'll move in i was
like
well you can't get any worse yeah so
it's up from here
um it was minus seven and minus eight in
the winter
and that said oh man it was cold but i
looked back now mad
you know what though it just shows how
bad things can get
and and also without knowing prop you
you had a little bit of
knowledge you obviously knew how to
raise money
you knew a bit about a little bit about
property you know
but a little bit of knowledge can be
very dangerous
it can be it can be it can which is
where education has
a huge amount of value yeah you know and
then actually
um got a bit more training and and and
put in a few
things that you know stop that ever
happening again yeah um
so what about the biggest win like
what's the i mean
that that deal was awful and what year
was that
was that it was fairly early on yeah um
it was after it was ironically after i
bought that first house but that that
was
then rented to a family because i moved
in to help my parents this is
probably around about 2013. something
like that it's a shame because i started
my training 2014 so if only
but hey what a lesson yeah and investors
got paid back now
oh yeah i mean they'll pay back it was
just a few months late
yeah a couple of investors um i'd raise
money to pay them out i said look this
is all went wrong
one other investor i said i'm
doing this deal it is coming there's
been a delay
i didn't tell them what was going on um
but i just said
it's coming it's just going to be a
little bit late yeah we're totally cool
with it what happened to the deal in the
end did the deal come off in the end
so i eventually with solicitors involved
etc got paid out
and just basically walked away from the
deal um i was in bristol the other day
and
i went past it it has been knocked down
so yeah
they might have got ahead and done it
but when we were talking like five years
later
yeah um they've obviously done something
with it but i don't really know
yeah what about the biggest win when
when did you at what point did you
realize
you know what i'm actually making good
money now this is
really sweet um i did in 2016
was my first like real big win for me uh
i've done a few little deals which are
all right by refurb
rent out but i bought a
huge three-bedroom house in stoke on
trent uh for
73 and a half thousand this is the one i
sold you is it it's not no yours is
wolverhampton okay
um but actually you did find me a
manager for this one okay um
at one point so 73 i spent 20 on it
um i then refinanced it um after
two years and that was a valued at 125
and i pulled 90 out
nice so it was a it was a a money out
deal it should be
two years to kind of refinance and
everything but in the meantime i found a
rent to renter who's like i want to take
you for two years and i'll pay you 800
pounds every month
thank you very much yeah so 800 pounds
about during that time i had no mortgage
on it
so with the exception of the bills it
was like
six seven hundred quid straight in my
pocket every month no mortgage on the
house
and he was managing it rent to renting
so he organized everything
yeah he was like yes i'll have a few
more of these please
no money down as well you pulled all
your money all money out and actually to
be fair an investor gave me the
75 and a half grand anyway so there's no
money down here there's no money down
um we financed pulled it out and it was
like how much did you
have to pay the investor back and how
did that work what was the contract uh
so
i paid um
half of the uplift yeah um i just said
look
it's gonna be a couple of years are you
okay and then yeah yeah fine
so they put all the money and they got
50 of the up left but was it in your
name or there that was in my name
actually that was in your name
they had the first charge on it okay um
so what two took a little time for me to
get the money out
see when you know how to speak to people
how to find deals how to
you do not need your money no no you
don't and again it wasn't a hard sell
hi mate how you doing yeah i found a
little deal this this this
it's a two-year time period it's gonna
give you this much profit from this
match in
what do you reckon sounds amazing all
right do you want me to
send the solicitor's details to you yeah
no problem and like that afternoon it
was like signed in across some
solicitors this is what we've agreed
um go that's great oh amazing i think
there's three types of deals there's
deals that
underperform there's deals that perform
and then there's deals to over perform
sure i mean at the moment that is rented
um with a manager and like you know
that's a grand plus
um every month i think that i think i
remember that deal actually
yeah i think i remember that it was
around the same time that we were doing
stuff who was the
uh not the name but how did you find the
rent to renter how did that come about
so um i think i might have trotted into
your office yeah i've got a little deal
um did i find that person yeah you did
oh there we go
[Laughter]
you jumped the gun but yeah i didn't
know i'm sorry i
yeah i think you probably just went hey
guys i've got a rent to rent it was
anyone interested
yeah um but talk to me about the win win
of rent events because
you're you're an investor um
to me rent to rent's a bit um difficult
to get my head round
um that's interesting
and i i get why people do it yeah um
because
they rent the house from me at 800 a
month
and they rent out the five rooms at 300
quid
three six nine twelve thirty five
fifteen they pay me 800
bills and whatever they're probably
gonna make for 500 quid a month yeah
awesome the amount of effort that it
takes if you're not using a saucer
to go to a letting agent and go can i do
your job for you
and i see people traipsing around
agent after agent after agent trying to
find a deal
and to me it's like you're doing all the
work
you're not getting all of the profit
you're paying over market rent most of
the time
and you're not getting any uplift from
the property and if they put that much
effort into going to coffee with people
and saying this is my business plan do
you want to fund the next deal they're
gonna be making a hell of a lot more
money
i think it depends on what you want um
and listen i'd never say you're wrong
because everybody has got their own
thing if you want to get
two thousand three thousand pound a
month cash flow coming
in and you want to leave your job and do
property i personally think rental rent
is probably
the best way of replacing your full-time
income going full-time into property
getting the learning getting the
experience getting the cash flow
you might scoff at 500 a month ago it's
only 500 a month they've got to do the
effort they've got to manage they've got
to be responsible for it but actually
500 should be a minimum it could be more
but you only need four of those replaces
an average salary
i tell you what doesn't make sense
working 40 hours a week
for 2 000 pounds a month working your
ass off
for 40 years to retire on 40 percent of
what you couldn't afford to live on in
the first place
that doesn't make sense i love that
quote yeah yeah so yeah so i i mean
listen from your perspective you might
say i got this house i don't want to
manage it
yeah rental renter give me my give me my
guaranteed rent you might say that for
me but from their point of view
they're happy to do it oh yeah and
another thing as well is you are quite a
um
frugal property investor that wants you
know you're a businessman
totally so so they might give you a very
good monthly rent but often when you're
rent a renter
you're gonna say look you got no late
payments guaranteed rent no maintenance
no management
you you're marketing this place for 600
quid how much you're gonna be left with
after you've paid maintenance management
and all that
or maybe four four fifty all right i'll
give you 450 guaranteed
and then suddenly you've got the the
uplift profit
and you've knocked them down a bit yeah
so so you know depends on obviously
there's good and bad rent around sales
yeah yeah but for me everything i do i'm
comparing to
using someone else's money by refurb
refinance
getting a free house yeah that's because
that's my kind of
cookie cutter if you like so i compare
everything to that
yeah and i have people that say hey do
you want to come and build a block of
action yeah i'd love to show you the
numbers
another thing do you know what i can buy
a flat
so here's my strategy every year i will
look at the
average wages for the year before
so to give you an idea um 2019
from one of the accommodations it was
but it was six thousand six hundred
eleven pounds was the average uk wage
for 2019.
cool 2020 that's my minimum profit yeah
okay why i made it out
and if i only do one deal i'm still
making the average wage and i'm not
going to
starve to death yeah okay i'm not going
to end up in the shed again i'm not
going to have
a really difficult conversation with my
investors if i'm making
36 grand per deal yeah 36 6 11
if i'm buying refurbishing and selling
that's my that's my number so what you
want to make
you want to make the minimum wage per
deal
yeah okay yeah why not so
you wouldn't want to do a deal if it
made you 20 grand
no can't be bothered yeah because the
effort
i'm at a level now where i can go now i
don't want to do that i'll wait for the
next one but at the same time if i'm
then waiting and waiting and waiting and
not doing anything i'm wasting my time
yeah so there's always got to be about
so you'd rather do less deals
but did good ones yeah yeah and that
changed over time at the beginning i was
like 10 round of deal yeah i'll buy it
you know i'll make 10 grand i'll do you
know multiple products i guess you don't
want to be a busy fool
yes and i always say when you whenever
you're working on business you need to
ask two questions
am i learning and am i earning
are you learning are you earning in the
early days you'll take on a deal that's
going to make you 10 grand because
the learning you're going to get from it
alone is worth it even if you made a
grand
yeah it's worth it but when you get to
the point where you've done it you've
done it you've done it
you don't need to do it for the learning
so suddenly it all becomes about the
earning it all becomes about the money
yeah it does
yeah with the exception of if i can buy
a refurbished refinance and pull all my
money out and not make that
it's a free half that qualifies yeah
exactly so those those little ones that
you know i'll do
yeah so what's the next boston it's
plans from here what's the what's the
goal over the next
couple years the next couple of years uh
i started my whole property business to
buy an f35 ferrari
um i haven't bought one yet um i want to
buy one of those in there what are you
driving right now i saw it outside it
was a crazy car
you might have a little clip of me
coming in um it's a
1985 rover three and a half liter sd1
v8 it's a little toy um the plan was
this year i was going to buy the ferrari
um but lockdown happened and that took a
lot away
from my war chest my warchest being your
save your bum money because for the
first time ever i managed to have a
completely
empty portfolio how did that happen
because
rent to rent when it all goes tough
go bankrupt and hand you the houses back
so all your houses are on rent events
with individuals
some of them were holiday let's i was
managing but no one's going holiday
doing lockdown
wow and the single legs i do have just
happened to be empty at that time
oh man this is stressful wow
but okay i've got a war chest just pay
the mortgages pay the mortgages and i've
got managers back in
i've got nurses injured locked down it's
like okay change the strategy what's
going to work people are going to need
to
not be at home because of this virus
thing all right nurses going in
i've got rooms available you know phone
the hospitals phone charities who've you
got
and eventually it was like nurses in
i've got
managers i was telling people around
about
july august time i was saying to people
now's the time to get rent to rent
dealers if you're looking for rent to
rent because
all these landlords have had their keys
handed back to them from the rent
juventus
with empty properties july august time
now's the time and you know what no one
listened to me because they're
all scared you know they're all like oh
i don't know fear and greed the two
things that affect the market
so do you think that um normal agents
are much less motivated to fill it out
the definition definitely you know
they rented renters have to do an
amazing job to get paid
yeah if that room isn't full they're not
getting a lot of their
profit so that makes a huge difference
to them
um a letting agent has got you know 150
properties and they're making 50
from each one if one room isn't full you
know it's like maybe a fiver to them
it's it's such small effect on them
and also you're not important another
thing is with estate agents is it's
normally not their business so you might
be dealing with someone that's getting
paid you know 18 grand a year
and they might get a peerly commission
whereas rent to renters normally you're
dealing with the business owner yes
so they tend to be yeah i would i would
agree with that yeah and i'm not by any
way shape or form knocking letting
agents because some people do
amazing stuff um but just from my
experience
and my reasoning behind giving my stuff
to rent to renters
which ultimately caused me a load of
headaches in lockdown
yeah but you know we had um
we had funds behind me um and also at
the time because
as you probably know from the car i'm a
bit of a petrol head
and i've got a collection of 16
motorbikes and whatever i know i've seen
pictures of
yeah big old cars yeah i've got 1920
stuff i've got
you know v8s i've got um
loads of bikes from you know v twins if
that means anything to you
right the way through to modern stuff um
but
uh yeah so in the lockdown um my local
bike shop where i'll go and kind of
get trade-ins and that kind of thing and
then do them up and sell them a bit like
property really
um they said look you know our service
manager's leaving do you wanna
come and work it's the middle of lock
round i can't do any
property networking events i can hit the
phones but i can also do that in the
evening because
you know no one's no one's going out to
work much
and i said yeah you know what i'll give
it a go yeah so so i've i've managed the
workshop in in
uh yeah um doing lockdown of you know
quit now because we're out the other
side but um you know that was fun
i'm not one for sitting indoors uh all
day i like i'll go
absolutely stir crazy so it was really
good that i i was able to go out the
house
yeah um i was able to deal with people i
was about yeah i could play with
motorbikes
that's your love isn't it and it's like
in the same way as well sometimes
you know people will say to me why do
you bother doing this and that and it's
like
what am i going to do am i going to just
sit at home
or lana beach and when everyone else is
at work this is
what people don't get when you go
full-time property
you can spend a lot of time with you
know other people that are in businesses
and property but we're also running
businesses so
if you have selected today that you're
just going to enjoy yourself and do
nothing
there's no one else around everyone else
is working or running their business and
doing stuff
it's like okay what do i want to do all
right i can ride motorbikes yeah i can
drive my car around you know i can
restore to my bikes um
but then what it's like ah there's
there's
you know i can go traveling but a lot of
the time everyone else is at work
so manage your time
yeah and do you think that um there's a
real
lack of education around business
finance investment just generally in
this country yes
why do you think that is i think there's
there's
there's lots of myths and there's lots
of fear yeah
um if you you know if you want to get
involved in finance
get some education um you know
understand the business
you're going into understand your
obligations under the fca
um and make sure that you're on the
right side of the business and then
bring people in to do the stuff that you
don't want to do that have the skills
that you don't
yeah so for instance you know i
outsource to the philippines
um i've got team members they're very
good at spelling because
you know i'm dyslexic and can't even say
you know but that that's my weakness my
strengths i can go out
meet people talk to people make deals
make money
get tenants in do all the hands-on stuff
that's what i love and when i go home
i'll play my cars play my motorbikes do
all that kind of thing
yeah and other than that what am i going
to do
carry on buying houses that's what i
love and this is what
property gives you the freedom to do
yeah but going back to the education
thing there's not much finance
education in property because at the end
of the day
if you're dealing with other people's
money you have a lot of responsibility
the other thing is if you're dealing
with money that
has passed you from an unethical source
you can end up with 10 years of jail
yeah but if you don't do that and you've
got a couple of things in place and they
give you lots of money that's genuine
you can end up with a lot of money in
the long run yeah
so so it's super important to be it's
like any business you know
people that say you don't need to go on
property training and get trained you
can just get it for free online i'm
thinking
this is the most lucrative business on
the planet what
why do you think that to be a
hairdresser or an electrician or a
plumber
or anything an accountant oh you need to
go and get trained you need to go to
college you need to go
but to be a property investor you don't
it's almost an insult to the property
industry
it's crazy and you see a lot of people
making
some really bad calls and you just think
like
just use it as my college education
yeah you know i didn't go to college i
didn't go on very well um you know when
i do the training programs
that that you know you run and other
people run that's kind of like my
college course
yeah um you know if you're doing a
business finance and you want to go
up a level and be paid more people go
and do a course and
i don't know why people are so
anti-property training
um in in general um yeah
and most of most of my training i put
out for free well
exactly on youtube and the crash course
and stuff
what what's what's your strongest reason
for doing this like i get you love bikes
and motors and
you don't want to have a bit of time
freedom as well yeah what's the real
strong reason that you do this
my family's one um
so before my parents passed away i said
to them i'm gonna look after the family
so that's a massive driver
um i want that ferrari and the longer i
put it off the harder it'll work
i'll work to buy the next couple years
um
and freedom to play my motorbikes you
know what
i'm a simple kind of guy and i love what
i do um
and if i wasn't gonna do anything i'd
buy hazard anyway
yeah that's so good so what was your
final piece of advice someone watching
this now that's thinking josh
you know if you can do it and you're
you're an average guy same as me
average guy you know not from a wealthy
family you've been homeless
um you've had situations where you're
sleeping in the car
you definitely weren't born with a
silver spoon in your mouth no
no you know you can but you can work for
it but what would be your final
you know what would be your final piece
of advice for someone watching this
what's the real
the key to your successing property
there's two things
one is just get started yeah
okay the second thing is get properly
educated
okay so you know coming to courses um
you know talk to people
team up with people that are doing it
that's still education because you're
learning
make sure you do it the right way from
the beginning and then you'll be fine if
you blow it
blow your pot at the beginning or you
blow your investors at the beginning
it's it's
very difficult to recover um and
enjoy it yeah and most importantly never
give up what brilliant advice josh
it's a real pleasure man i love to see
you winning thank you so much for giving
your time up to come on here
uh if you want to connect with josh josh
connect you can connect with him i'll
leave his details in the description
also if you want to watch josh's last
interview that he did with me uh almost
two years ago now you can check that out
right here
if you want to see a whole playlist of
people winning smashing it in property
as a result of the training that i
provide
you can see them all up here right here
and please do me a massive favor and
subscribe to the channel
right down here thanks so much guys i'll
see you next time